Gary what did you want to say to me what
what's uh going on with you is he now
coloring his hair hair looks darker
today I am not coloring my hair I'm not
coloring my hair no he's not coloring
his hair I saw him in you know uh Gary
came over for my birthday and I hung out
with him I got to say Gary's the
heaviest I've ever seen him really right
I can't I don't think I can argue with
you are you thinking about zemp Gary uh
I thought about it but I'm I just I I
feel like it's crossing a line I don't
know nobody else does like I have tons
of friends who are doing it and uh I
don't know but I'm no I'm not I don't
think I'm doing it he can take it off on
his own he's got to get back on that
pelaton and he's gota I was on the
pelaton the other day I was all right
doing my but I got it I mean I here's
the crazy thing Howard I do I swear to
God I work out every day I do like an
hour on the elliptical or I do the um
really the pelaton but then I [__]
eat snacks like crazy all day long what
are your snacks what are you snacking on
H lots of chocolate right then like um
um dumb [__] like uh like Wheat Thins
and you know and
pretzels and plantains stupid [__] like
that you go you're going down you ever
have a meal I
mean is it constant eating yeah he's big
he's a big boy he he he has a meal on
top of his plantains and his chocolates
Wheat Thins don't even taste good Howard
and he's chomping those well you know
what it is in Gary's mind it's like well
it's not that many calories cuz it's
kind of like not as big as some other
things yeah yeah then he polishes off
the whole box I get it you know Robin
you're right it's not potato chips right
so I'm already on a diet I'll be it's
ironic I eat Wheat Thins and I got wheat
fat Gary told someone I happen to no
this I I shouldn't be telling but Gary
told someone he gets the shakes if he
doesn't eat enough chocolate like he
starts to shake his body so he's in B
trouble well first of all every like
once every six months I go off chocolate
for like a couple of weeks like two or
three weeks I go I like really don't eat
any of it and the at the end of the
first day the headache that I get is so
unbearable oh that's crazy it sounds
like OIC was made for
him some days I just take I have a jar
of peanut butter and I just take
chocolate chips and I pour it into the
jar and then I just eat it out I just
eat God you're in big trouble you toothy
Winnie the Poo like what do you weigh
now about uh
217 uh Samantha who works for us thinks
Gary is lying about his weight and is
demanding that he get on his scale hey
I'm not I feel very bad I'm not trying
to shame Gary I think everyone here lies
about their weight by 8 lbs what do you
think he weighs I think he probably
weighs 2
223 I'm not trying to shame anyone but
then what are you trying to do I'm
trying
to sorry I mean why else would you come
on except to shame me but that's okay
she's probably right Howard I so 217 was
what I weighed the scale do you have a
scale there was what I weigh last night
when I got out of after I worked out I
was naked so I'm probably 223 let's go
see I'm I feel bad welcome to my world
I've been feeling bad since
1971 I believe why should he be the only
one all right what do you wa Gary
22.4 oh oh you're pretty good Sam wow I
think you look great Gary I I don't
think it's like oh you look big you're
lying about your weight I just think now
you feel so bad you're you're telling
him he looks good listen everybody knows
what everybody does on the show just own
it okay I I'll own it I I I do have an
argument for I think Gary should go on
OIC why because I think you look great
and all that however I think if you come
to a point in your life and you can't
lose a certain amount of weight it could
start affecting you know your your blood
sugar your heart all the all your
kidneys all that stuff maybe OIC is the
answer it's going to save your life with
someone like you Ser Sirus you are
exercising all right so you weigh 220
maybe you if you took 20 pounds off
you'd be you know for 20 pounds to go on
a drug that's how I feel seem kind of
crazy yeah I I I'm sorry say I think I
disagree with you on
this if Gary's like 59 or 510 I don't
think should be two okay so he's 5'8 I
don't think he's supposed to be 200 lb I
think he's supposed to be more like 180
I've been 190 19 I've been 190 and I
look I think I look very skinny but
that's yeah that's 30 pounds away and
it's it would make a difference well
Gary you got to get on this we got to
get on top of it Sam says you should be
doing mosic I I think you could get it
under control on your own but uh he's
done it before he just has to develop
some new habits I'll tell you the worst
part is we have a big meeting today of a
bunch of Senior Management and I'm going
have to eat in front of everybody now
and what are you going to be eating I
don't know I don't know what they're
serving you don't have to eat Gary what
do you mean I got to freaking eat I I
can't skip a meal oh oh yeah like you're
going to die if you don't eat this lunch
just everyone who to the meeting today
I'm not starting the diet today so don't
judge what's on the menu I don't know I
don't know M&M's Pizza
lasagna
hogies